eight people have been injured in a
shooting in occupied east jerusalem it's
believed the gunman targeted passengers
on a bus and in a car as well as
pedestrians the police haven't ruled out
the possibility of more than one shooter
israeli forces are searching in the
district of silwan natasha gunaim has
the latest from occupied east jerusalem
israeli media is reporting as many as
eight people were injured in this
shooting two of them seriously one of
them is a 35 year old woman who is
pregnant according to media reports
at least one person ambushed a bus as it
arrived at the western wall in the old
city on sunday morning witnesses say
that as people were boarding the bus and
it was packed they heard gunshots
screams shouting and warnings that this
was a terror attack a bus driver tells
israeli media he tried to pull away but
he was unable to do so because the
wheelchair ramp had been lowered to
accommodate a woman in a wheelchair and
it blocked the door preventing him from
leaving police flooded the area cordoned
off the area near the western wall and
since then have been raiding several
homes in a palestinian neighborhood in
occupied east jerusalem called silwan a
short time ago there were alerts that
four people have been arrested two of
them women and they might be possibly
related to the suspect as i said there
are reports that there could be one or
more shooter there is actually cctv
footage that shows someone shooting at
the bus that no doubt will be helpful to
police as they search for the person or
people responsible the shooting comes a
week after egypt negotiated a ceasefire
between israel and the armed group
palestine palestinian islamic jihad in
the gaza strip that followed three days
of israeli airstrikes in gaza that
killed almost 50 people including 17
children israel says it conducted this
operation to thwart a terror attack by
the islamic jihad the ceasefire had been
considered quite fragile because islamic
jihad is continuing to press for the
release of two prisoners including a man
who has been held without charge for
months and is on a hunger strike and is
in very poor health
yoni ben minishim is a senior middle
east analyst in west jerusalem he says
the attack follows a week of high
tension in israel gaza and the occupied
west bank
the atmosphere is the atmosphere of
tension
or frustration
the palestinians are very frustrated
from what happened
in gaza
for them it was a defeat
of the
palestinian islamic jihad the pig
because
israel made a successful successful
operation
and
now
of course there's a ceasefire but still
the tension
is very high because the islamic jihad
demands the release of two palestinian
prisons
prisoners and
i don't know if it's still it's only
speculations we don't know if it's
directly connected but
the atmosphere
is of tension and frustration